c'est une affaire pour le moins
embarrassante qui colle aux baskets du
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
une accusation de viol qui depuis sa
nomination au gouvernement suscite bien
des polémiques
d'autant que médiapart vient de publier
de nouvelles révélations qui ne devrait
pas calmer la sphère en 2017 sophie
paterson spads porte des accusations de
viol impliquant gérald darmanin elles
l'accusent d'abus de position et
d'agressions sexuelles à son encontre
aujourd'hui ce sont des sms qui sont
publiés par mediapart des échanges
supposée entre gérald darmanin et celle
qui se dit sa victime sur les sms on
découvre que le ministre aurait insisté
à de nombreuses reprises pour boire un
verre avec la jeune femme
malgré son refus catégorique des
échanges et une insistance qui ont mené
la supposée victime a invectivé l'homme
politique abusé de sa position pour ma
part c'est être un sale con des sms qui
met le ministre de l'intérieur dans une
situation bien délicate
alors fallait-il révéler les sms privé
de gérald darmanin et florian ceni qui
nous a rejoint expert en communication
politique il a fait de nombreuses
émissions avec moi notamment balances
ton post merci d'être là contre lorient
afp jour en bocaux subhawong et la
politique les ça rigole pas sur un autre
délire pensé qu'il fallait les révéler
géraldine maillet mutation mediapart
révèle et puis après la justice enquête
- n'approuve rien en fait
ça prouve juste que c'est enfin on peut
être quand même un chaud lapin on peut
être un peu tard on peut être un
séducteur sans être un criminel sans
être un violeur
on va tomber en train de tout mélanger
en fait c'est toujours pareil on est à
partir du moment où un homme aujourd'hui
tant en plus a été classée sans suite en
fait car il sait sa femme a fait moins
pour l'instant il n'y a pas d'affaires
abc florian florian en fait la sphère a
été classé deux fois mais oui voilà
ailleurs un juge d'instruction a ordonné
un non-lieu à veut dire que la justice
n'a pas réussi à poser sur ce dossier
une qualification pénale
il est difficile aujourd'hui pour la
justice de mettre un délit sur les
agissements du ministre alors on peut
considérer qu'il a été lourd et les
ministres à l'ordre
je vais vous lire les sms
ils sont énormes alors et sms sur les
normes ce et c'est juste un gars ses
juges de galles le 27 octobre 2009 à
21h49 il écrit libre pour boire un verre
vers un gars qui râle on dirait moi
quand je me fais passer pour un ringard
ne peut contacter plus répond telles
armes
si tu veux même si j'aurais aimé prendre
un dernier verre
j'aimerais que tu me rappelles s'il te
plaît gerald ahoueya il faut pas celle à
l'histoire
après 4 novembre à minuit les cas
nouveaux venus à toi mon frère et mon
numéro
ok mais prenons un dernier verre mais
c'est moi qui me suis fait passer pour
kavanagh mais sans déconner vient après
le 8 décembre
ils vont encore la voir so j'aimerais
vraiment tu m'accordes un autre dîner ou
un autre maire je t'embrasse elle répond
le 7 décembre
elle répond pas son enfant en cette fin
d'année acceptes tu de boire un verre ce
soir dans la nuit du 16 au 17 décembre
elle lui répond par un message
incendiaire abusé de sa position pour ma
part c'est peut-être ainsi être un sale
con surtout quand on est dans la peine
la politique te correspond bien quand on
sait les forts qui là qu'il m'a fallu
pour béziers avec toi pour occuper de
monde aussi
et voilà et il a pris là répond il
arrive il a dit tu as raison je suis
sans doute un sale con comment me faire
pardonner
plus tard il renvoie merci de me
redonner une chance et tu dispo dès ce
soir par mail il lui envoie la copie du
courrier à la mise dans lequel il
intervient pour l'aider il enchaîne
c'est ok pour ce soir un verre à la main
vers berlin deux heures sans réponse il
insiste peux tu me dire pour ce soir
afin que je m'organise 22 heures c'est
trop tard manifestement tu ne veux pas
me voir mais sait-on jamais tu peux
quand tu veux je bosse n'est pas
répondre à 22 heures je suis accompagné
et ne peux te contacter pour le moment
il relance au quai vers minuit et après
le roi voilà après mars à vélo mais il
est lourd et mais assez serré mais les
lois et des brouillons il est lourd mais
il est pas mal élevés comme digère ligne
arrivants qui prouve un viol la dent en
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que la
nature de leur relation
c'est sûr qui a pas eu d'histoire
d'amour elle à chaque fois il renvoie ce
qu'elle voulait qu'elle est je crois
pour un dossier judiciaire lui il est en
train de la drague et à chaque fois elle
ramène toi celle d'ivoire quand est-ce
que tu mettes pour mon dossier
moi je pense que ça en dit long sur la
nature de leurs la saga ciné à bonduelle
acceptent d'aller dans le club attend
avec lui et elle accepte après neil à
l'hôtel c'est ce que je vous dis de
cette affaire moi je dis qu'il est
révélateur de notre époque
aujourd'hui on est systématiquement
qu'on fasse de la politique ou pas
d'ailleurs n'importe toutes les
personnalités exposées on rentre dans
leur chambre
on sait tout d'elle
moi j'ai des clients qui toute la
journée se plaignent que leurs textos
soit inondent les médias les textos
privé c'est priver sa vocation
j'aime beaucoup entendre ou jamais
marine qui sont de très bons je trouve
que médiapart ils font des enquêtes et
est-ce qu'on avait récemment qu'ils sont
voilà moi j'ai vu une enquête sur le
refuge qui m'a voilà qui va avec qui est
sorti dernièrement
voilà il ya des très bons jeunes
journalistes aussi à médiapart mais
comment comme moi je moi j'aimerais ça
va être deux points les bulls où ils
viennent ses smsc l'asa cite c'est une
bonne question quand même parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un secret de
l'instruction et qui est pénalement
protégé et il ya un secret de l'enquète
ces deux principes fondamentaux qui ont
vocation à nous protéger chaque étage de
oui car il est justement parce que l'on
en attente d'une décision de justice
définitive qui dira si vous êtes
innocent ou coupable
on doit préserver la vie des gens moi
aujourd'hui j'ai des clients qui me
disent on va se suicider alors que des
décisions arrive assez vite mais
toujours trop lentement quand on est
accusé pour les innocentés mais en
attendant aura été répétée en boucle un
certain nombre d'accusations qui auront
détruit leurs familles poussées leur
femme a divorcé et ses bas ils auront
perdu leur job leur boîte aura coulé
tout ça ça a des impacts et donc quand
on est journaliste on doit aussi mesurer
qu est la différence entre la protection
de la vie privée et l'information au
public moi je trouve que ici quoi qu'il
arrive au fond et j'en termine là asie
c'est d'abord vous savez quand il ya
toujours un quand il ya un petit truc de
dégueulasse chez ceux qu'on jalouse chez
ceux qui sont exposés
bah c'est tentant d'aller regarder ça
fait de l'audience et donc au fond c'est
aussi l'intérêt des médias que diffuser
ses informations un peu dégueu souvent à
la limite de la loi pas regarder pour
vous faire de l'audience et dans parle
aujourd'hui mais c'est vrai et voilà
après oui si on reprend le havre et à
mon avis elle qui l'ont renvoyé mais
laissez passer sur ses cendres il
bah oui mais c'est réussi simon prend
des textos j'écris j'ai pas ya cinq ans
six ans à 100 sur contexte sans
expliquer la situation et conditions
reprendraient dès lors les vuvuzelas je
vous ai écrit voir non mais voilà donc
si on en croit les textos que je voulais
explorer n'est pas bien c'est chaud
c'est chaud là au mauvais choix oui mars
les alors ça ne c'est pas vrai c'est
dramatique et non on se pousse à des
relations avec sap et benjamins qui
cherchait via des il ya des animateurs
dont on ne citera pas nombreux qui
disent ouais je vais ressortir mais
c'est les mêmes a sonné
c'est tout le monde sait que quand j'ai
quelque chose à dire à quelle heure
après tout voilà gentiment on a eu un
accrochage avec barnetta inler par
sort-il sms
jamais jamais de la villa jeu sorti un
livre c'était plus rentables après les
relations hommes-femmes voici si
quelqu'un que j'ai côtoyés chez pas
qu'on ressent des textos que j'ai pu
envoyer un peu un peu coquin peu chaud
mais soulage postface pour qui est ce
que vous avez déjà la scène live adressé
aux jeunes filles qui sont là je suis
sûr et certain que tout ici vous avez
reçu des sms de l'ogc nice ils bavardent
mec un peu relou et voulant me geraldine
à oui biensur problème ouais bah oui
même genre mais qui reste toujours au
loup qu'on soit envoyé des sms à
mediapart est inconnue mais vous non non
non non annoncé comme en soit là dessus
est ce que vous en avez reçu je vous
montre où les gens et j'en ai reçu et
justement c'est pour ça que ce genre de
personne ce sont des forces heures ce
sont des lourdeurs c'est insupportable
il a envoyé 36 message
quand on dit non elle lui dit non dans
le moulage à lui dit fou - la paix il
lui envoie 36 message donc j'ai j'ai
vécu ça et c'est trop vous avez vécu ça
c'est bien sûr qu'avec assad il ya cinq
six ans et est d'une lourdeur a brief
que tu es à la presse il ya des femmes
qui passera dans le moi je moi je savais
tu arrivé à oui bah évidemment s'y
exprimer
mais je vous dis que c'est vrai c'est
tout l'intérêt d'angola pas devant si
c'est non non non j'ai alors oui mais si
elle atteint baptiste après tous les
écueils position arrive la fin dont on
parle d'ailleurs a été condamné parce
qu'elle à ars et son exploit et nous
voilà ça a été jugée alors ils avaient
tous vous avez déjà eu des rôles ou par
maintenance et les g
oui bien sûr des lettres dg des lettres
de pdg et gdc sms et puis les sms vous
même à mon âge car y'a des gérontes ou
si vous n'êtes pas des vêtements dit
pardon delphine toi toi ça doit être un
truc de fou j'en ai reçu remet plus
avant que schumi
je n'ai reçu et bourges en même des
hommes d'un certain âge qui avait une
femme aurait quitté leurs femmes leurs
enfants dans le maine juste parce que
lui souriait il a cru que non mais nous
oui alors on était très potes mois avant
que tu sois mis aussi ah oui oui
écrivait exact je serai à risque ont
passé et se complètent bien de son
ancien numéro 06 24
33 c'est ça ou pas 49 49 c'est ça ouais
les mecs me plaît quand même nom monde
entre pote jean et moi c'est vrai mais
pour le coup pour gérald darmanin pardon
moi ce qui me dérange c'est qu'il use de
sa médiatisation et de son pouvoir à des
fins sexuelles non c'est non c'est non
c'est pas tout alla s'est passé en soi
pas dire ça dessine non non non non
lalalalala vous allez aimer ça
non mais c'est donc sur d'innocence à la
présente c'est pas ça apparemment ils
ont eu une aventure
après voilà après ça chez sa famille et
lui il était un peu relou avec elle
c'est ça en fait oui d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui les soupçons qui pèsent sur
lui c'est pas tant la question du viol
que celle du trafic d'influencé et
est-ce qu'au fond elle était dans une
position suffisamment de faiblesse pour
qu'elle soit par crainte de sa grâce à
ses paroles le polaris en l'état et ça
n'a pas aidé montrer les justin n'a pas
réussi à le démontrer donc peut-être que
les choses changeront mais en l'état
c'est pas le cas et la difficulté c'est
qu'on a un ministre qui est entravée
aujourd'hui dans son action politique
alors qu'il a quelques résultats hillary
les issers emmanuel macron et le prémice
aujourd'hui il a permis le dialogue avec
la police qui était quand même vraiment
très compliqué extra mais tout cela
c'est masquer est occultée et parasité
en permanence par ces accusations
il n'y a pas de décision de justice et
c'est avec condamnant gérald darmanin
mais il ya un top tweets avec un corps
social qui sait est malade mais agissent
comme une étiquette que la justice ne
lui a pas qu'on est exactement ça fait
deux fois donc que l' affaire a été
classée sans ces deux fois et un non
lieu par un juge d'instruction ça fait
donc trois fois que la justice dit qu'
il n'y a pas lieu à une qualification
pénale ce qui s'est passé c'est que sans
doute très certainement les avocats de
la plaignante craignent que la sphère
soit définitivement enterré et c'est
pour ça que dans ces cas là ils se
disent qu'il faut médiatiser syrie c'est
ce qui se passe dans certains c'est pour
ça que ça sort parce qu'il dit si on ne
le fait pas là si on ne fait pas publier
ça aujourd'hui et les médias se ruent
dessus
effectivement la sphère est enterré donc
la plaignante dit à ses avocats ok on y
va mais ça c'est très intéressant que
c'est un symptôme de notre époque
aujourd'hui moi dans tous les procès
qu'on accompagne à médiatique on a
soi-même on a des morceaux de dossiers
qui sont balancés au grand public qui
nous
rien dire et parfois même d'ailleurs les
journalistes en font une interprétation
qui est contraire à ce que les
enquêteurs comptent affirmé dans le
dossier malheureusement nous on ne
dévoile pas les éléments du dossier et
la difficulté c'est que les gens se font
un avis définitif et accorde une
culpabilité en fait il ya une justice
populaire qui est rendue avant la
justice judiciaire
oui le temps de la justice il est trop
long mais on devrait pas jouer à ce jeu
là parce qu'on peut tous être concernées
par des accusations portées contre lui
on va voir ce qu'en dit des trucs
oui à 53% non à 47% oui la majorité 10
juillet